not only do you not care about the truth
you don't care that you've created a
nuclear holocaust in someone's life it
doesn't matter to you so long as you get
yours we did a life advice segment
yesterday so send your emails to life
advice at lateraled credit.com ii was
actually tough love with your guru dr.
Trott I can't claim him a doctor but
really I'm a doctor we did that whole
show yesterday for those who are mug
Club members so it's often I'm inspired
with this this last segment by a
particular email but that we went to
what five six seven they met six people
seemed to enjoy it and and hopefully you
know what helps helps me people out
there let me let me be really clear
about this you know sometimes some of
these segments are a little more flowery
sometimes I get emotional I'm just gonna
you know I'm a little bit emotionally
drained it's been I have just been
pissed off all day I'm not gonna I've
been pissed off all day I've had this
hearing on and I of course had to take
notes write down time codes what's being
said I've had to try and fad this whole
time to wasted a ton of time trying to
fact-check evidence that wasn't really
evidence only to realize that it didn't
matter anyway and wasted a whole lot of
my time it was just like up just up just
a pissed-off firehose just to have any
which way but loose although it was it
was loose
wasn't it fire hoses they're loose in my
heart but the point is I'm pretty tired
that being said this one's easy
this one's did you watching the hearings
when you're thinking about how to
navigate it there's one thing that
matters and there's only one thing that
matters truth that's it truth is what
matters if you go through this process
if you go through you know if you go
through life seeking truth if you make
that your number-one goal and I know
some people right now Egyptian myth just
let's just drop that let's drop the the
factions for a second okay we're talking
about truth overall there are people you
know there are people I know it's pretty
easy to see if someone is consistently
seeking truth or to live in truth in
their life notice I didn't say your
truth doesn't say my truth the truth
there is no my truth there is no your
truth there is no fords truth and
Cavanaugh's truth there is the truth we
don't know the truth right now this is
why this is why this met and this is why
i get so frustrated with the media
coverage
we don't know the truth do you know why
because human nature if left to its own
devices is not truthful that's why we
have the justice system that we do
that's why it's innocent until proven
guilty you've actually thought of that
maybe set them hold on a second
why is it innocent until proven guilty
because I wasn't always the case we want
to return to the city do you want to
turn the Salem witch trials and I know
it was lejana and no no listen that
wasn't always the case in every single
society to out to be good people when
people talk about hold on a second
morality is is is is circumstantial
it's it's societal okay maybe that's
true because some societies didn't value
mercy that's why I think that you get
your mouth you get your values and your
any only able rights by a creator I do
believe in God you don't have to but the
truth is not always these have the same
values the jury is not not all religions
share the same values they don't all
worship the same God but have you ever
actually thought about why is it
innocent until proven guilty why did we
when setting up a system on how to judge
people on how to parse information did
we say all right we're gonna have to
assume someone's innocence until they're
proven guilty it's because we know that
if people can use lies to further their
own personal position to advance their
own personal gain for power that they
will we know that you see it in politics
you see it in the entertainment industry
if people can lie and if they can do so
undercover
if they can be protected by lying and do
it for personal gain
that's why someone's innocent until
proven guilty there's a reason for it
it's so that we don't just say believe
all survivors that's exactly why it's
innocent until proven guilty how do you
know what's a survivor we have a process
to find out of it to survivor there's a
reason for it and we've gotten so far
off of the beam of seeking truth here's
here's another little throat you the
left the progressive left the people I
don't mean ever but people like The
Young Turks people like the Feinstein's
they don't not only do they not care
about the justice system anymore not
only do they not care about rule of law
not only do they not care about truth
they're just gonna do damage anyway even
if it's not true even if it's not proven
true this is the difference now in the
era of social media this is why truth is
more important than
because now you don't just lose your job
you'll lose your whole reputation the
way information spreads it's like being
able to kill somebody without a shot
fired you can do it through telekinesis
Kyle if you were able to do that just in
an empty gun that's what yeah I've got
an empty gun but I can kill you anyway
so like men you stare at ghosts you just
I can cause spontaneous combustion
they don't need Cavanaugh Toby they're
not even pushing for a trial
we can't even compare it to the Salem
witch trials because someone was burned
at the stake at the end of something
that they saw with some sort of justice
in this case these are just people who
we don't know the exact motives but we
do know that they don't care about
damaging someone's reputation and that's
the thing about the untruthful that's
why it's so important to keep bringing
yourself back to the beam for truth I've
talked about the most toxic lies or not
only lies that you tell other people but
the lies that you tell yourself because
then you get to a point where you can't
even identify the truth if you don't
start if you don't continue and start
every morning coming back to that that
that beam of truth even if it's if it's
a one inch tight rope and you're on
water skis if you don't make an effort
to you get to the point where you don't
not only do you not care about the truth
you don't care that you've created a
nuclear holocaust in someone's life it
doesn't matter to you so long as you get
yours and let me be really clear if
Cavanaugh raped as many people who've
come forward I think it's up to 219 now
it's like the McDonald's ticker how many
billions served he is the most
successful rapist of all time and I
personally on an emotional level would
actually like to see see someone like
that get the death penalty and I know
people disagree I'm making a point here
let's not get lost in the weeds and the
death penalty for rapists but let me be
as clear as possible if he raped all the
people who accused him of it throw the
book at him
but if he didn't I feel worse for Brett
I feel worse for potential justice
Cavanaugh than any man that I can think
of in recent memory so I'm saying fry
him or my god my heart goes out to him
and I just want to give the guy and his
daughter and his family a hug polar
opposites
there's only one difference between the
two it's the truth
hey there you were if you liked this
video watch one of my other videos
oh it's playing in one of those boxes
I'd say subscribe or hit the
notification build but I don't really
know what that means in today's day and
age on YouTube but if you join it louder
with Crider comm slash mug club you
won't only see clips you'll get to watch
the full daily one-hour show every
single day and support our content
making sure that we can still get clips
up here on YouTube for the freeloaders
who can't afford it and/or are just
cheap pricks